[Music]
hi my name is Chris Gagne and I am an
agile coach I've coached over three
dozen teams in both huge enterprises and
small companies prior to that I have
close to a decade of product management
experience that makes me a bit unique
among agile coaches who often come from
scrum master project manager and
engineering manager backgrounds I've
been in the trenches just like you and
I've seen more than my fair share the
good the bad and the ugly
this video will introduce you to the
five most common events in scrum I've
included dozens of unique tips and
tricks that will help your team get the
most from these events with a lowest
time investment the five events that
I'll cover
are backlog refinement sprint planning
daily scrum sprint review it's Brett
retrospective you can watch them all or
click the links in the description to
jump just in the section that you need
enjoy and thanks for watching
[Music]
backlog refinement is the work of
refining estimating the ordering items
in the product backlog as a product
manager I used to spend about a quarter
of my time working on my backlog the
scrum guide suggests that the
development team also spent up to 10% of
their capacity supporting backlog
refinement this usually happens in
regularly scheduled event such as
backlog refinement and sprint planning
but it also occurs ad hoc such as in a
parking lot discussion after the daily
scrum although backlog refinement isn't
an official event and scrum guide I've
never met a scrum master or coach who
didn't advocate strongly for teams
making it one as a general rule I
discourage work from being introduced at
sprint planning
unless has been previously been through
a backlog refinement event with the team
the biggest reason for this is to reduce
risk
if your team can't clarify an items
requirements during sprint planning it
won't be ready to pull into the sprint
and will likely have to wait for the
next one if the product owner attempts
to force it into the sprint anyway the
team sprint forecast will not be very
accurate however if you hold a backlog
refinement event a few days in advance
of the sprint planning and the team
discovers an issue you'll have time
before the sprint starts to do more
research besides every hour your team
spends in backlog refinement is at least
an hour your team won't spend in spring
planning before you start I suggest
having a product owner communicate a
proposed list of items for refinement to
the team at least a few hours before the
event this gives the team a chance to
look at the stories earlier if the
product owner or scrum master are
willing to conclude the event when all
of these items have been refined rather
than move on to new topics
it can also be highly motivating for the
team to begin gather the whole team and
start discussing your highest ranked
backlog Adam remember the phrase card
conversation confirmation the card is
the index card sticky note or software
entry that acts as the token for our
discussion our discussion is the
conversation the updates we make to the
card especially the acceptance criteria
lead to the confirmation what's the
scope hata scope dependencies target
chip date keep talking about and
updating each backlog item until it
meets your team's definition of ready
then estimate if you're using planning
poker to estimate items do so
immediately following the discussion so
that is still fresh in your mind if
you're using affinity estimating you can
place the item in its correct relative
location immediately after discussing it
or wait until you've discussed
everything to sort them once the user
story is ready and estimated market is
ready I'd like to preface the items
title with an asterisk to indicate that
it's ready this works great when you've
got several pro forma sprints lined up
following your release
planning session if you don't do release
planning you can simply create a pseudo
sprint called ready and place items in
that sprint schedule your backlog
refinement events as your team sees fit
I generally suggest one shorter backlog
refinement event per week lasting in
about an hour for mature teams and
products some teams like one longer
session per sprint if your sprint
planning event seemed to take forever
you probably need to spend more time
doing refinement this is especially
common for new teams or products sprint
planning is an event in which the entire
scrum team collectively determines what
work can be delivered in the next friend
and how that work will be completed
there are several steps in sprint
planning first close up the last sprint
if the team hasn't done so already
update and close last friends board any
remaining work should be carried over to
the next friend unless the product owner
feels that it is no longer valuable
otherwise the team should assume that
some work in process on those tasks will
have been wasted this is because it
takes more effort to recruit and pick up
where the team left off when they
stopped working on a task for a sprint
or more second determine your story
point budget for the next sprint based
on your historical performance and
capacity and next friends capacity there
are a few techniques for calculating
your budget the most common are rolling
historical average in yesterday's
weather but describing them would take
too long what really matters is to
stress how important the team treat this
empirically if the data tells a team
that they consistently complete about 20
points of Sprint they should not attempt
to complete 25 points the following
sprint out of wishful thinking better to
sign up for 20 and pick up the five
points mid sprint when all of the work
has been accepted
I find it here instance evidence based
limit to be a powerful predictor of the
team's overall capacity for empirical
process control and thus our overall
success of agile third all those good
practices start sprint planning with one
and a half to two Sprint's of stories
that meet the definition of ready pilot
owners and teams often find that they
will want to introduce a new unrefined
story for consideration in the next
sprint for instance many teams find that
they almost always have an improvement
item from the retrospective or a
customer may have requested a small but
important change in the sprint review
this debt looks just like backlog
refinement discuss refined split and
estimate backlog items fourth load
stories into the sprint backlog
respecting this branch story point
budget based on a good faith estimate
that the complexity uncertainty and
effort required for new and old backlog
items the historical performance and the
calculated budget for next sprint the
team publicly forecasts that they will
complete these backlog items by the end
of the next iteration especially for new
teams it can be helpful to use the fists
of five voting technique to gauge the
team's confidence in the forecast fifth
the team should discuss and commit to a
sprint goal this break goal guides the
team as to the purpose of the work they
will be doing over the next iteration
for instance a Sprint goal might be
launched the new analytics beta to 10%
of her customers it should be possible
to meet the Sprint goal without
completing the entire sprint backlog for
instance most of the Sprint backlog
might be a must-have for launching the
beta well a couple the backlog items
might be should house the beta can be
launched and thus the Sprint goal can be
met without these should have items
being completed six the team should
discuss how it will complete the items
in the backlog this typically takes
about half the time allotted for Sprint
planning
so be sure to allow enough time for it
starting at the top of your sprint
backlog the development team will
discuss each item and decide how it will
deliver this functionality in the sprint
as you do so create a sub task on your
board for instance suppose the team
wants to add a new validation error to
the page there may be a task to write
the test another to change the logic
another to update the CSS and another to
kick off automated testing and
deployment some teams especially newer
ones will also estimate the number of
hours each task will take to complete so
they can watch these burning down along
with story points over the course of the
sprint following sprint planning any
member the development team should be
able to articulate what the Sprint goal
is what the team expects to complete in
at least of a high level how the team
will complete that work one of my
favorite tricks as a product owner was
to ask the team to spend the 24 hours
following sprint planning validating
their plan for the iteration especially
if the last step of planning how the
work will be completed is cut short
through the time box when that grace
period ends I would send an email to all
of my stakeholders reporting on what we
completed last Brent what we forecast we
will complete this brand and the Sprint
goal that we've committed to you this is
a great follow-up to the Sprint review
because it give stakeholders a preview
of our next iteration one of the biggest
mistakes I seen teams make is not
allowing enough time for sprint planning
or doing enough backlog refinement in
advance sprint planning should take one
to two hours per week planned so to
experience should take two to four hours
to plan if you're finding that it's
difficult to complete sprint planning in
this time box including determining how
that he will do the work you may need to
do more backlog refinement or evaluate
how this event is facilitated
[Music]
let me start by setting with the daily
scrum is not the daily scrum is not a
status review or report for anyone
including product owners scrum masters
or steak lovers this is both destructive
and common enough that I feel it's
important to call this out right at the
beginning instead the daily scrum is a
chance for the team to transparently
inspect and adapt how their sprint is
going it is an opportunity for course
correction not micromanagement even the
physical orientation of the participants
at a daily scrum is telling are they
collaboratively huddling in circle or is
there one person in power at the front
with the rest of the development team
meekly answering questions I say this
because the driving ethos and daily
outcomes of your team's daily scrum are
more important than its exact
manifestation that said here's a format
that I found works reasonably well first
start the daily scrum at the same time
in place every single day some teams
like to skip the daily scrum Mondays
that they conduct sprint review and/or
sprint planning but this is a missed
chance to reconnect before these
important events ideally your team
should have a dedicated space with
either a physical or electronic task
board and burn down chart visible to
everyone if you are distributed or
remote video is better than audio start
at the daily scrum on time even if much
of the team is missing within a few days
attendance should improve this being
late to a meeting in progress is more
uncomfortable than being late to a
meeting that hasn't started yet
next each development team member
answers three questions right from the
scrum bride as concisely as possible
what did i do yesterday that helped the
development team meet the Sprint goal
what will I do today to help the
development team meet the sprinkle and
do I see any impediments that prevent me
or the development team from meeting the
Sprint goal as the member of the
development team is speaking watch out
for the following
first is everyone else looking directly
at the person speaking and paying full
attention it can be a fun game for the
speaker to look for anyone who isn't
paying attention and nominate them as
the next speaker second are they
speaking directly to tasks that are
visible to the whole team on the board
or they're working on something else I
once had a mentor who told me that we
should consider any effort towards
working not on the board as an act of
sedition because it deeply impacts the
product owners ability to support the
team and saps a team of velocity made
good against the Sprint goal third
sometimes answering these questions can
spark an intense discussion in order to
get the dalish come to 15 minutes or
less any team member has the authority
to designate the current topic of
parking-lot item to be discussed with
any interested parties immediately
following the daily scrum any individual
who does not wish to be present for that
discussion need not attend next examine
the team's burned down chart and
incomplete sprint backlog items does the
team still feel confident that they can
meet the Sprint goal and finish
everything in the sprint backlog by the
end of the Sprint and no meeting the
sprinkle and finishing everything the
Sprint backlog are not the same thing if
not why is there a course correction
that will enable team to succeed if not
should one or more backlog items from
the bottom the Sprint backlog be removed
this inspection and adaptation will
improve the team's chance of success and
give the product owner a chance to
provide really warning to their
stakeholders if the goal will not be met
a couple of other useful hints it's not
the scrum masters job to always
facilitate the daily scrum only to
ensure that it happens smoothly and
within the 15 minute time box also
people who are not on the team are
always welcome to attend so long as they
do not interfere with the event for
instance watch out for stakeholders
demanding status updates or addition to
the current Sprint's backlog these sorts
of requests should be directed directly
to the product owner
that's the essence of the daily scrum
feel free to experiment with a format be
sure to track whether or not your
experiment helped your team meet the
Sprint goal or provide an early warning
[Music]
sprint review is held at the end of
every sprint to celebrate the team's
success inspect the product increment
delivered by the development team and
adapt the product backlog is necessary
it's also an opportunity for the scrum
team to demonstrate transparency about
their output and process to their
stakeholders so as to foster mutual
trust the event is attended by the
entire scrum team and the stakeholders
and customers invited by the product
owner some teams find it useful to
complete their first review or to
privately so they can get the hang of it
before inviting stakeholders and
customers that stakeholders to attend
many disorganize events may not come
back for more here's a sample agenda
that covers the most important points of
a sprint review first
the product owner welcomes their
stakeholders and exists finds what
product backlog items have and have not
been fully completed second the
development team briefly talks about
their experiences during the Sprint
including any impediment set of rows and
how they resolve them know that most
teams complete their sprint
retrospective event after the Sprint
review so they think include what
happened at the sprint review in the
retrospective so be aware that you might
not have the most refined responses yet
also this isn't an opportunity for
stakeholders to criticize the team's
process if a stakeholder has this type
of concern they should discuss it with a
scrum master and/or product owner after
the event
third the development team this
demonstrates each fully completed
backlog item ideally from the end users
perspective show results not code
demonstrating backlog items in stage and
can illustrate that the work integrated
correctly while demonstrating from
production is nice it's not necessarily
required
stakeholders should be encouraged to ask
questions and provide feedback and
anyone on the team can answer forth the
product owner can share for looking
updates what's the current state of the
backlog have any longer term forecasts
such as release date and scope changed
5th all attendees participate in an
adaptation exercise having inspected the
product increment and backlog presented
transparently by the scrum team
what adaptation should we make it can
also be helpful to talk about the
changes in the market or other team
external events that could impact the
team's future plans the primary output
of the sprint review is an updated
product backlog that reflects the event
this event can take up to one hour per
week of iteration but most teams and
stakeholders will want to complete it in
less time typically 30 to 60 minutes for
a two-week sprint
the retrospective is far away the most
important event in scrum if not for all
IGEL practitioners
although empirical process control is
omnipresent scrum no where is it better
representative than at the retrospective
put another way
ISIL envision a team being highly
successful even after they've jettisoned
every other rol artifact an event so
long as they're still doing
retrospectives this is because a team
can experiment of changes to roles
artifacts and events not to mention
plenty of other factors using
retrospectives for instance suppose a
team decides during the retrospective to
reduce the time spent doing backlog
refinement by 50% and there's still
generally happier that choice a few
Sprint's later who as I said that
shouldn't make the change so how can we
conduct our first retrospective
personally I'm a huge fan of the five
step retrospective popularized by us or
Derby and Diana Larson authors of the
book agile retrospectives making good
teams great retrospectives can get stale
really quickly so teams find it helpful
to change how they do retrospective
often so long as you're a retrospective
covers the following five steps you're
in good hands step one is to set the
stage this is a good chance to break the
ice with your team and remind yourselves
why this is so important I have a few
activities I like for this step and I
recommend choosing two of them first I
suggest reading norm curse retrospective
prime directive as a team which is
regardless of what we discover we
understand and truly believe that
everyone did the best job they could
give him what they knew at the time
their skills and abilities the resources
available in the situation at hand this
helps to create a collaborative
environment for learning and continuous
improvement instead of blaming
individuals second I like to ask each
team member to share just one word about
how the Sprint went for them
this will give everyone a good sense of
the mood in the room third I'd like to
invite team members to share a genuine
word of specific appreciation for
another member of the team step two is
to gather data what happened in a
misprint I like to use a positive
Delta's and insights collection device
ask each team member to come up with as
many positives deltas or things they'd
like to change and insights as possible
have them write each positive Delta and
insight individually on sticky notes or
their digital equivalent when the team
is run out of thoughts where the time
box has elapsed place the sticky notes
on the wall in group like items together
step three is to generate insights I
like to add a brief intermediary step
which is to choose the top positive
Delta's and/or insights that we'd like
to focus on about one to three total
once you have the top one three items
dig in more on each one the book agile
retrospectives has a good activity
called prioritize of thoughts that can
make this go faster if a positive reads
the team is doing a good job of
collaborating with one another then a
delta reads our staging server keeps
going down try to understand the root
cause of these conditions some teams
find it helpful to ask why five times
give or take
until you get to your root cause as all
retrospective suggests other exercises
as well as a hint if you're rarely
surprised by your root causes you may
not be digging deep enough step four is
all about actions I like to expand those
into decisions and actions for each item
discuss as a team suggestions about how
you can persistent deep and positive
change or minimize the Delta and
capitalize on the inside you'll find
that your suggestions naturally fall
into two buckets decisions which are
changes to your team's working agreement
and actions which was simply new backlog
items suppose the team is tired of event
starting late due to tardiness the team
could vote to add a rule to their
working agreement that imposes a penalty
for being late or suppose a team
discovers that their staging server
needs several hours of maintenance the
team could decide to add a user store to
the backlog that reads as a developer I
have a more reliable staging server so I
can develop software more effectively
trying to stay focused here it's better
to have one or two improvement items for
the next iteration and then have to much
to change all at once step 5 is wrap up
if you haven't done a round of
appreciations yet this is a nice time
it's been a few minutes retrospective on
the retrospective how did it go for the
team what would they like to try next
time your team should run a
retrospective at the end of every sprint
if your team is doing Kanban or one-week
sprints it's okay to do retrospective
every two weeks it's also useful to hold
a retrospective at the end of any
significant event chose as the multi
team release planning a large release or
following an incident if your rest
respecting an outage or incident don't
call this event a post mortem this makes
the event a little too negative in
consumption suddenly implying that the
team killed something or someone instead
just used retrospective or the military
term after-action review so that's a
reasonable retrospective format that you
can use for your first several sprints
talk to your team's agile coach for more
ideas on how to keep your retrospective
fresh and interesting
you